hi my name is Jamie mcpartland I'm an
assistant professor in the Yale autism
program with a child study center though
out of the program is a group of
scientists and clinicians that work
together to try to understand the causes
and develop treatments for autism
autism is a behaviorally defined
disorder and by that I mean make a
diagnosis by comparing what we see in
child or in a person with a list of
symptoms that are in a diagnostic manual
social behavior communication and then a
third category repetitive and restricted
behaviors I mean things like strong
interests or repetitive movements this
is going to change this month this will
involve a regrouping of the symptoms
into two categories social and
communicative difficulties and then the
same kinds of rigid and repetitive
behaviors it's very important when
diagnosing autism to be sure that you
have a sense of how a child has changed
throughout development and to get the
respective both from a clinician who
works with a child and also with the
parent who really has the best sense of
what the child is like there are a
number of studies at Yale looking at the
genetics of autism
one that's particularly exciting right
now
a very large project it's directed by
dr. Kevin Pelfrey it's an autism center
of excellence network that involves Yale
the University of Washington the
University of California Los Angeles and
Harvard and what we're doing in this
project is looking at girls for focusing
on girls with autism autism affects
girls at a much lower rate than boys and
so we're we're using this multi-site
approach to get large enough numbers of
girls to really try to understand the
specific genes involved how they relate
specifically to behavior and brain which
we're measuring using
electroencephalography and also
functional magnetic resonance imaging
treatment for teenagers with autism is
fortunately an area that has really
grown there are a number of manualized
treatments for teenagers with autism as
in any aspect of autism treatment or
trying to learn about autism the
treatment really needs to vary by the
characteristics of the person there are
a number of things going on right here
at Yale Dennis Sadowski is involved in
cognitive behavioral therapies for
anxiety
irritability and teenagers with autism
Pamela ventola and expert in pivotal
response therapy is developing
applications of that kind of treatment
for teenagers as well psychoanalysis and
autism has a complicated history in the
1950s
and psycho psycho analysis was a very
common approach to understanding
behavior there was a idea that autism
was caused by parenting styles and we
know that that's not true the other
autism is based in jeans and based on
biology
the reasons a person chooses to behave
in a certain way are very very
complicated to understand from a person
who isn't the person behaving and that's
true for a person with autism and it's
true for people without autism many
times people with autism can act in ways
that are considered rude by other people
but it's unintentional one of the
difficulties that many foo dog doesn't
have is understanding the feelings the
thoughts the ideas of other people and
put being able to put themselves in
another person's shoes so your question
makes me wonder if this person that
you're having difficulty with might
benefit from a conversation with you
helping him understand how their actions
are affecting your feelings whether
oxygen can be cured or not is a very
controversial question with a behavioral
diagnosis like autism you either show
the behaviors and make diagnosis or you
don't and so if you gave very effective
intervention to a person with autism or
if they learned a great deal they may no
longer show these kinds of behaviors and
they wouldn't qualify for a diagnosis
what's tricky is that they
the same genes and the same brain
structure that they had when they were
showing these symptoms and so it's
essentially a moving target we we might
see a child who isn't showing autism any
longer in say five or six years old
because a very effective treatment but
the risk is that if we remove services
for this child as social interactions
and communication got more sophisticated
the same brain that had difficulty
learning these skills in the first place
might have difficulty learning them anew
so there are absolutely studies that
show that there are people with autism
who no longer meet diagnostic criteria
the use of the word cure is a very
controversial term in autism research
you